with salvaged wood
you can find all sorts of things
oh there's bee stuff here too that's
four nails in this thing already
there's another one over here i kind of
feel like this log is a bit uh it's got
a bad attitude
part of the fun i'm griffin ramsey i'm a
chainsaw artist in austin texas
i've been carving for nine years today
i'm going to be turning this
into this using these
i'm going to start carving by blocking
out which means removing the bulk of the
material the stuff i know isn't going to
be there
as few cuts as possible and saving as
much of that wood as i possibly can
and that's the big center piece where
i'm going to want somebody to sit
i'm going to be doing the blocking out
with the steel ms
261 which is a heavier saw and it has a
standard guide bar on it which means i
need to be really careful so i don't get
any kick back
i'm trying to keep the pieces that i'm
removing as large as possible to be used
for other carvings later to conserve the
wood as much as possible
oh should just be stuff here too this is
an eastern red cedar log i found it in
east texas from a guy i met on facebook
when he
salvaged it he found this giant beehive
in the middle of it
it's really rare in texas to find
something this size and it has a hollow
center because usually
eastern red cedar when it gets this
large tends to go hollow in the middle
and so uh the shape of it seems like
it'll lend itself well to being a chair
so now i can see how far the hollowness
goes down
now that the big chunk has come out and
i can see my seat
it's time to start cleaning out the rot
and finding the good material so i can
know what i'm even working with
[Music]
all right so i'd hit some metal you come
take a look over here
you do not want to find metal with your
chainsaw it takes a chunk out of your
chain usually or maybe multiple places
on the chain
and sometimes it can ruin your chain it
happens
for events and stuff you'll have people
with a metal detector go over the log
beforehand i didn't do that
that's one of the downsides i guess of a
salvaged material is that often it has
like random
issues the rot is kind of
random i think it's going to be all
about like cleaning out the wood and
finding the good wood first and then
determining the design based on that
[Music]
do you know how fast the chain is moving
around the bottom chainsaw
i should know that actually i don't know
let me i'll google it
how fast does a chain spin in a chainsaw
you can assume the chainsaw motor is
turning at
12 000 rpm 12 000 revolutions per minute
that's fast 22 revolutions per second
[Music]
i'm just switching bar and chain it's
too hot to touch
ouch people ask me if i've ever hurt
myself on the saw the thing i
the only thing i ever really do is
burning myself like when you try to do
things like this when it's still hot
there's different chain styles for
different things but this is just a
regular
bar and chain you can buy at the store
one clear way to tell if your chain is
dull your
sawdust gets really powdery any time
your tulle is dull
you have to work a lot harder and it's
at least not like a knife where it's
going to slip
and be more likely to cut you but it's
making my life harder to have a dull
chain
and if your tools are sharp you have
more control
and you're going to save way more time
by not having to fight the wood as much
here's an upside of having a doll chain
though it's less likely to over grab or
be aggressive and sometimes when you're
doing some like
really smooth areas or like sometimes
some of the front extreme work i don't
mind having a bit of a dull chain
less aggressive i just put on a new
chain
and of course the first thing i do is
hit metal there's another one over here
ah that's four nails in this thing
already these two
that there's one on the back that i
found a minute ago over here
looks like maybe it was a fence line
staples with wire in it that's a major
pain there's like a whole
lot of metal in here so i think i'm
going to switch for a moment to the
power gouge
because i can kind of hollow out a lot
of this rot i can't really get in there
with the saw safely without just using
the tip so i'm going to try to use the
power gouge
the power gouge moves a lot of material
too so that'll save some time
hollowing this out
the power gouge throws bigger chunks
than sawdust because it has these little
scoopers and so they're like larger
pieces of wood and they can kind of hurt
when they're thrown and they tend to
throw right back
up to your face so i wear the face
shield with the helmet combination when
i'm using the power gouge
if i do it straight on it makes these
two gouges and two grooves
which if you're doing like a frantic
texture is fine
but if you're trying to sculpt with it
it's a little bit better on like one
edge
i think i can get in there with the
carving bar a little bit easier the
heavier the saw the more work the saw
does
and then the lighter the solder more
work you do
[Music]
now that the rot is mostly gone i can
start shaping the good material into the
chair
carving bar is great for shaping but it
also creates a lot of interesting
textures
i kind of use it for everything i can
rasp with it
rasping is kind of when you like scratch
the surface side to side
straight down similar to sanding but in
a way that's a lot rougher
it's a way to clear a lot of material
and sort of just scratch it off
scoring is when you make a cut but not
all the way through so essentially just
creating a line
because the carving bar tapers if you
just make your cut immediately all the
way in
that base is going to be a lot more like
a typical bar
which is going to make more like jagged
straight looking cuts if you
score and you keep going a little bit
deeper at the same time then you can use
that tip
which is going to make a better curve
for you more like a jigsaw
[Music]
i like switching to the lighter saws
because by the time
i'm ready to my arms are tired so it's a
relief to have the lighter weight
and you can go a little bit longer it's
more like free moving it's light
i'm more connected to it in my body the
downside is that
it's not as long of a bar and so i'm a
little bit limited to what i can reach
as i keep whittling the seat further
down um to just make sure it's even and
then sort of account for what is going
to be comfortable
i keep noticing that the arms then are
too high so i'm trying to get the arms
down to what's comfortable
where the seat is going to be and that
is shifting as the bottom shifts
you want to go as far as you can with
every saw you're holding when you think
that you have finished with one saw do
one more tank of gas
with it and push yourself a little
further with it
i use gas saws as well as electric and
battery but there are some situations
where some work better than others
gas is more powerful and faster for the
most part
and since i'm working outside i'm using
gas although the batteries are getting
better and better
and the battery saws now are getting
really strong
based on the color the organic flow of
it
i think it'll look really good as flames
so just like sitting in a bunch of
flames
like in sitting in the middle of a
campfire almost
so the next thing to do is to finish
the areas that i've started clearing out
that aren't totally cleared out so these
inclusions
either that came from rot or from the
natural inclusions of the cedar because
cedar tends to grow in on itself
so i'll go in with the saw clear those
out even more
and then start to shape them into flames
so it'll be following the natural flow
of the wood
but then giving it some assistance to
make it sculpted into flames and so
actually it should look kind of cool at
the end because
even just in the natural twists and
turns of the wood itself it already
looks kind of flamey
especially when poking through some of
this lighter material the combination of
the blonde and the red it's going to
look really nice i think
this is the baby it's the cutest
chainsaw you've ever seen
the steel ms-150 with the eight-inch
carving bar with the dime tip and the
tiniest little chain you've ever seen
i use that for final detail stage
[Applause]
[Music]
today i'm using it to carve around the
tips of the flames
especially except when they're getting
in too deep then i have to use the
longer bar but at least for around those
little
delicate curves and sort of on the
inside
where one object meets the next that
little
line that separation that's what that
thing is great for
[Music]
another good thing about eastern red
cedar is that when you're carving it it
doesn't tend to get too fuzzy
that's kind of nice because you don't
have to do nearly as much drying and
sanding later
[Music]
i'm switching to the angle grinder and
the dye grinder to start smoothing out
the areas i've already shaved with the
chainsaw
chainsaw carvers tend to be more afraid
of angle grinders
than chainsaws
i've injured myself the most on these
two tools
and they are pretty intense and
aggressive and it can be scary and they
don't look like it like the saw looks a
lot more threatening
it's so close to your fingers so you
have to be really careful i have one
where if i let go
it stops so you see it's still spinning
for a while so then a lot of damage can
be done from when you let go
there's a certain stage where you don't
really want to go back to the chainsaw
because it makes a huge mess throwing
bar and chain oil all over the wood and
if you've already sanded you have to go
sand again
i use the ankle grinder for a lot of
things it's really powerful tool
and it makes a great sander but really
aggressive sander that you can also
shape and sculpt with it moves a lot of
material and then the edge can be used
to make perfect little lines
[Music]
this really aggressive bit on the dye
grinder is great for clearing a lot of
material especially in those hard to
reach places that it's hard to get with
the saw
and it leaves a somewhat sanded finish
at the end of it
it's really important that the inside is
sanded because i want somebody who's
sitting in there to feel comfortable
and i don't want them to be jabbed in
the back and as i'm sitting i'm
feeling areas that are bulging kind of
weirdly and it makes me sit
not quite centered and so i'm smoothing
as much as i can so then
a person can sit there and feel
symmetrical
since the hole in the center of the log
is still here at this level
and i don't want anyone to sit in a hole
i'm adding some western red cedar planks
i had around the shop
to make a seat and then i'm using the
same planks to make a little side table
i'm happy with how this chair is turning
out but i think it needs a little bit
of burning to bring out the shadows and
to define those flames
so i'm going to use my map gas torch
map gas burns hotter than propane and so
it gets into those cracks in between a
little bit better
the cedar when i burn it it smells like
incense
i love it
when using the torch you have to be
really careful not to
catch things on fire i have in the past
actually
lit myself on fire during a live carving
show because i wasn't paying attention
and i was burning and it lit some of the
sawdust on my table
on fire but i had holes in my table from
the chainsaw and so it fell down
underneath
and mixed probably with some gas and oil
and at some point somebody shouted and
said hey
you're on fire and i looked down my leg
was there's flames creeping up my leg
and i had to like pull my angle grinder
everything out luckily somebody was
there with a fire extinguisher
and uh we're really quick with it
this was sort of a discovery process as
i was like taking out the metal and the
rot and
didn't really know what the outcome was
going to be had sort of an idea where i
was going but
it's changed a lot over the course of
the journey and
i'm pretty happy with it i think it's
kind of metal i think we took somewhere
between 400 500 pounds probably off of
the
log that we haven't tried moving it yet
so we'll see
alrighty there you have it one giant
cedar log three chainsaws
couple of grinders 12 hours and now we
have
a throne of flames
[Music]
you